CBS this morning in focus is the
original reporting you'll see only on
this broadcast exposing new information
on issues that impact us all so today
we're hearing from a Louisiana man who
spent 17 years behind bars simply
because he looked like a serial robber
Erin Moriarty shows us how this case
clearly illustrates why eyewitness
testimony once considered the gold
standard of evidence results in so many
wrongful convictions good morning Erin
sounds like 17 years are wrong oh this
is such a scary story
good morning of those who've been
exonerated by DNA evidence nearly
three-quarters of them were convicted in
the first place because of faulty
eyewitness testimony what happened a
royal Clark junior you will understand
why I can never imagine going home I
thought I was gonna die up there royal
Clark was 24 years old when he was
charged and later convicted of an armed
robbery at this Burger King in November
2001 in Tarrytown Louisiana did you rob
that Burger King was the assailant used
a cop seen in this crime-scene photo and
left fingerprints but the prints were
determined to be unusable three Burger
King employees picked Clark from a photo
lineup but by trial only one of them a
19 year old was sure what does that feel
like when you know you weren't there and
this witness is saying it looks like him
like everything sit down at the moment
everything got quiet the witness who was
the same race as the robber and got a
good look at him convinced the jurors
royal Clark was convicted and sentenced
to forty nine and a half years what was
your reaction when you heard the
sentence I wanted to pass so at the same
time I wanted a last show Clark's
appeals were denied and his newborn son
grew up without him how old was your son
when you went in yeah my son was like a
month
a month old when you were incarcerated
taking care of him from the diapers to
the clothes to the books you know
educating him burying him explaining to
him life you missed all of that I missed
all of that and then in 2018 Innocence
Project New Orleans took his case
attorney Kea Hayes hope for DNA testing
of that cup but investigators never
collected it there were only those
unusable fingerprints we thought well
wait a minute you know maybe we can
reanalyze the prints and see if that can
find the actual perpetrator my reaction
is do it
I wanted to know district attorney Paul
conics office convicted royal Clarke but
he agreed to have the Sheriff's
Department crime lab we analyzed the
prints there was a hit and it wasn't
royal Clarke somebody else entirely that
has a history of committing armed
robberies in the same area the
fingerprints belong to 54 year old Jesse
Perry currently in prison for several
other armed robberies Paul when you
think about this what if there hadn't
been a hit in fact royal Clarke would
still be innocent but he'd still be in
prison that is the tragedy that is the
nightmare so how did the eyewitness who
identified royal Clarke get it so wrong
unfortunately it happens all the time
Nancy Franklin a psychology professor at
Stony Brook University specializes in
memory memories she says can be altered
by time what's more the two men in mug
shots have similar features that is a
phenomenon called mug shot exposure
effect is it possible this witness was
actually remembering the mug shot yes
well then it makes sense why she would
be so confident about pointing to royal
Clarke yes just how difficult is it to
correctly identify a stranger's face
take a look at this man now choose him
in this
line up it's challenging huh is the same
man one of these ten I'm gonna have to
go with this one okay so you're picking
three and you're misidentifying an
innocent person the right answer is that
he's not there do you think there are
other royal Clark sitting in prison
right now I'm sure of it I'm sure there
are on June 27th one day after his 42nd
birthday royal Clark walked out of
prison with his now 17 year old son by
his side earlier this year the Louisiana
Legislature passed a law to try to
prevent these kinds of cases so for the
first time memory experts will be
allowed to testify a trial to try to
educate jurors about the risk of
eyewitness evidence but not a shot
exposure that mug shot tested the ends
are real I'll make the jury take that
test and they'll see a reliable or
unreliable it can be well and that's
well they probably should because I
really thought you know I was really
careful I thought I would get it right I
should point out that I did talk to the
eyewitness in this case
she's now 35 years of age she's
devastated and asked me not to include
her in the piece because imagine she put
this man behind bars but I also think
there's a real problem with the system
that they would allow one eyewitness yes
that much way they thought they had to
in them one at trial wasn't as short I'm
glad you point out I was the same race
that mug shot exposure is very scary
your heart goes out to Royal Clark and
special shout-out to Kia Hays doing more
good work but his son is doing great I
should point out that is a doll so Erin
thank you very much